the question in Hong Kong nowadays isn't
whether protesters will be on the
streets but rather which once they'll
take over coming up to the fifth month
of weekend demonstrations these latest
protests brought several districts to a
standstill nobody wants to see violence
but who is forcing us to come out and
March
it's our so-called chief executive and
so I came out today as I hope the people
of Hong Kong will not forget their cause
things have changed the demonstrations
used to be so peaceful before the day's
protests started as an approved rally at
Victoria Park attended by thousands of
people the gathering was led by
Democratic candidates standing in local
elections later this month the protests
gained traction after democracy icon
Joshua Wong was disqualified from
contesting the elections and move he
calls politically motivated but the
demonstrations soon turned violent when
police blocked protesters from marching
into the streets and set up a cordon to
prevent others from entering the park
less than an hour after the rally began
teargas was fired sending people
scrambling protesters shut down Main
Roads and took over Hong Kong's Central
District you can hear the sirens in the
distance and the air is thick with tear
gas and smoke but that isn't putting off
any of these protesters hundreds of them
are gathered here in Hong Kong's main
financial centre a place that is usually
teeming its shoppers during the weekend
and tourists instead the protesters have
taken over the street that built
barricades set public objects on fire
and are waiting for the police to come
here
and they came in large numbers firing
tear gas and pepper spray dispersing the
protesters in all directions they kept
with their philosophy be water to
regroup and disrupt other parts of the
city
protesters vandalized the offices of the
state-run Xinhua news agency widely seen
as the mouthpiece of the Chinese
Communist government
in an unusual move earlier this week
Chinese political leaders indicated that
Beijing is likely to intervene more in
Hong Kong's affairs in the name of
safeguarding national security some
protesters believe this could mean their
days on the streets are numbered how god
we all know that the movement will not
be able to get us what we demand yeah we
insist on being out here we fear that
this could be our last chance but for
now this tanned off looks like it will
continue despite months of street
protests Beijing looks set to harden it
stance while the activists are showing
they'll take to the streets for as long
as they can the big apollon are Jazeera
Hong Kong